in the Canadian Rockies a battle of
Olympic proportions echoes through the
mountains the contestants are bighorn
sheep young and old Rams alike looking
to make their mark the prize is mating
rights and a chance to woo the local use
with a number of males interested
there's only one way to settle the
matter head-butting they smash into each
other with 40-pound forms absorbing the
shock with double-layered skulls
whoever is left standing at the end is
the winner they are fierce competitors
strong tireless determined and willing
to use every trick in the book to
achieve victory this one pretends to
graze to throw his opponents off guard
an old ploy it doesn't fool the others
- I is a good tactic as are shots from
behind soften a ram up and a low blow
when no one's looking
the news watch and wait for a winner
but just because one Ram comes out on
top doesn't mean the females will accept
him after besting his rivals the lead
Ram now has another challenge pursuing
the females up Rocky Mountain slopes and
proving a strength once again the other
males unwilling to admit defeat wait for
their chance to bring the front-runner
down finally he proves his worthiness
the use consent their children will be
strong and Hardy
for now he is the champion until next
season when the competition begins again